okay it's been said a million times
but I feel the need to reiterate
because I just saw a video of a girl
you know in the age of trad wifery
okay this video is about trad wives um
or even just women who are like
staying home and cooking and cleaning
is so much better than being a corporate baddie
um I saw a woman who said
don't tell the feminists
but you know
I would rather cook and clean
and then people are replying and stitching and saying okay
but feminism is about choosing
like you get to choose whether or not you wanna be a stay at home mom
or wife or girlfriend or whatever but
or like being a corporate baddie
and I'm not stitching or tagging
cause I'm truly not trying to call anyone out
I just need to put it out there that you know
we've already been through this whole notion of choice feminism
and how feminism is not about women just doing whatever they want
and people just supporting whatever it is that an individual woman wants
feminism is about the liberation of the masses from patriarchal oppression
and there are a lot of women
and we see it with the trad wives
there are a lot of women who do not make choices that align with feminism
and I need to just write a substack
essay about this
because like
tradwife culture or like
women who are toying with the idea of just being stay at home girlfriends
or wives or whatever
like that's a direct consequence of capitalism
that's a direct consequence of like okay
the whole corporate baddie
like 9 to 5 life
you know that
you know feminism has tried to sell us
it's not all sex and the city
it's not all thirty
flirty and thriving
like this is not fun
working sucks
and yeah jobs suck
but that's why we need to become Marxist
feminists in the year 2024
and then comes the whole question of like
choice and seriously
I'm gonna write an essay about this
because it's too much to get into on TikTok but like
when you are choosing between the lesser of two evils
like between being a slave to capitalism versus being a slave to your husband
like is that actually like
even a choice
like that's the great tragedy of choice feminism
is that you're choosing between the lesser two evils
you're choosing
you know you're picking your poison
so is that really a choice like
are we actually even making these choices that you're saying that we're making
because you know
in a truly egalitarian
feminist society
the choices that women
you know non men
like everyone who is oppressed by patriarchy
like these choices that we're making
um they should be completely autonomous
they should not be made under coercion
they should not be made under threat of
like you know
either be a corporate baddie
or you'll go homeless or you know
either be a stay at home wife and mother
or go homeless
and like here's the disclaimer
if you have a partner
regardless of their gender
if you have a partner that you feel
safe and comfortable being financially and materially dependent upon
like if you are
you know the person who keeps house
and they're the person who goes to their 9 to 5
like great genuinely
good for you
but in an ideal world
nobody would ever be financially and materially dependent upon like
another individual
their society would just take care of them
regardless of what they do
regardless of whether they work outside the home or within it so anyway